president biden took careful steps in
buffalo a moment of national tragedy
felt so personally here he met families
of the 10 victims and paid individual
tributes
hayward patterson 67
father
church deacon
fed the homeless
at soup kitchen
gave rides at a grocery store to
neighbors who needed help
this is the soup kitchen deacon
patterson helped run
and in the church where he worshipped
simply shock and sadness i'm expecting
even now
to wake up and find out it was a dream
because it's just unbelievable
that someone would take him away from us
you know
he was such he wouldn't hurt a fly
he was just that sweet of a person is it
hard to keep going sometimes the thing
that i don't understand why do you need
assault rifles why do you need
guns
piercing what is it armor why do you
need military armor you're not in the
army
why do you need these type of weapons
that you you know that anyone can seem
like they can purchase and then come and
do this type of a
crime and that's the national challenge
following this local crisis
white supremacy is a poison
it's a poison
running through it really is
running through our body politic and
it's been allowed to fester and grow
right in front of our eyes
no more
i mean no more
his message felt powerful and personal
leaving buffalo joe biden knows his
sympathy will only go so far america
hears his words but what they want is
change laura bundock sky news in buffalo